Republicans are laying the groundwork
for repealing Obamacare I guess Trump
wants to do it he said during the
campaign that it's a total disaster and
has to go but then he met with Obama and
came out and said you know some of those
Obamacare provisions I like very much
but then his advisers got to him and
then he was back to it has to go it sort
of depends on who the person is that
spoke to trump five minutes ago that
determines which way he wants to go so
let's forget about Trump for a second
Republicans are moving ahead with the
infrastructure to destroy the Affordable
Care Act and a few things have been done
in the last 48 hours really the first 48
hours of the new Congress number one
there's been a budget resolution
introduced by a Chairman Mike Enzi to
jumpstart the budgetary maneuver known
as reconciliation and this is how
Republicans would be able to avoid a
democratic filibuster in the upper
chamber and it starts the procedural
process for repealing or defunding
pieces or aspect of the Affordable Care
Act here's the really rich party that
this is just incredible how you have to
hand it to them in terms of the evil
genius creativity Republicans led by
Steve King of Iowa real piece of work uh
they've come up with a bill which would
ban the Supreme Court from citing their
own prior Obamacare related cases for
the purpose of precedence in all future
cases here's a quote from Steve King in
a press release it was my first order of
business on the morning after obama care
passed into law March 24 2010 to draft
and introduce my full 100% repeal of
Obamacare by prohibiting the Supreme
Court from citing Obamacare cases we
will be truly eradicating this
unconstitutional policy from all three
branches of government so that the
repeal will be complete the bill claims
that under article 3 section 2 Congress
is allowed to quote provide exceptions
and regulations for Supreme Court
consideration of cases and controversies
so two thoughts on this number one that
is not meant to tell the Supreme Court
how to evaluate cases what that
provision is meant to do
as we heard uh actually from a number of
legal aspects pertz that's um there to
tell the court that their jurisdiction
can be limited on particular issues so
you could use article 3 section 2 to
tell the court here's one area that we
are removing from your jurisdiction and
you don't need to accept cases with this
regard it's not there to allow
politicians to tell the supposedly
independent judiciary what information
or evidence or prior rulings they can
and cannot consider when talking about a
particular issue so this matters because
precedent is one of the most important
aspects of the American judicial system
if you tell the Supreme Court you can't
consider your past opinions on this
issue you're actually eliminating a lot
of the infrastructure under which the
Affordable Care Act has already been
examined and upheld as constitutional by
courts up to and including the Supreme
Court will this work will like I said it
shouldn't it shouldn't work because this
is not the point the point of article 3
section 2 but you have to activate
around this and and you can actually
call the governor's office for this as
we've talked about before the Medicaid
expansion component of the Affordable
Care Act is something that individual
states have the freedom to decide
whether or not to accept I assure you
that there will be Republican governors
who have opted into the Medicaid
expansion if they get enough calls from
constituents saying hey do not allow
this to happen because I will lose my
Medicaid which I now have because of the
expansion that you signed into law that
will get the attention of governors and
usually it will call your member of
Congress call your representative
governors are much more administrative
as elected officials then our senators
and members of the House you have to
activate call your governor's office but
also you-you-you of course should always
call your local elected officials I
always thought that the Supreme Court
was a separate branch of government I
always thought Republicans wanted small
government
to allow for an independent Supreme
Court all of a sudden you've got the
Republican Party violating small-market
print up small small government
principles by starting to get involved
with the Supreme Court in telling them
what you can and can't consider when you
rule on a particular issue and they are
also attempting to eliminate the
Independence of the Supreme Court this
is America under Donald Trump or at
least it will be in about 16 days thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one remember we're raising
money to expand the David Pakman show
big league as well as expand progressive
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated